welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Marvel Studios officially
released a scene ahead of Ant-Man in the
west Quantum media that confirms that
King the Conqueror killed Thor in
another timeline
I don't know who you are but you've made
a big mistake I'm an Avenger I've called
the other Avengers you're an Avenger
have I killed you before what they all
blew together after a while you're not
the one with the hammer it's Thor we get
confused a lot similar body types now we
are not spoiling quantumania here this
is the detail that Marvel Studios
released ahead of the movie and let's be
honest something we've all been able to
assume based on Past trailer footage of
King hinting that he is killed all the
Avengers at some point killed everyone
at some point so much so then this is
the third in a win King killed series
because yeah you know that it's bad boy
cracked all of the skulls but Kang's
specific relationship with asgardians
like Thor are worth exploring based on
what we know from the comics and
leftover Clues and past Kang appearances
and he remains obsession with Thor's
Frost giant adopted brother adopted
based on all this I think we can narrow
down the exact moment in multiversal
history when it would have been the
likeliest for Kang to have given Thor
the business and we are one week out
from quantumania's released on February
7 18th and on that same day we will be
launching our new channel the Deep dive
where on Friday February 17th you can
join me for a spoiler live stream
quantumania live breakdown I'm so
excited for this Channel watch I'm still
doing stuff on new rockstars and I've
been getting three hours sleep nights
trying to get it all ready I don't have
time to brush my hair so please
subscribe at Deep dive INR okay Jonathan
Majors himself cut a promo for Thor call
in the God of Thunder to the mat when he
was asked which Avenger he'd want to
rumble with I think we have to start
with Thor yeah come on bring It come
here
start with Thor I mean I get it Jonathan
majors has been pumping iron for the
past 10 months going from Creed 3 to
magazine dreams so why wouldn't he want
to waste all that mass and call out the
beefiest boy in the MCU the way Thor
dropped in the battle wakanda and scream
Brewing move Thanos so now this quote
from Kang in quantumania you're not the
one with the hammer tells us that the
Thor that he vaguely remembers is the
one who is carrying mjolnir at the time
of the conflict so it's probably not
this period when Thor has been carrying
around Stormbreaker which is part hammer
really mostly battle ax so we are
looking for a time in Thor's life before
hella destroyed mjolnir in Thor Ragnarok
I guess maybe they're in the Battle of
Earth an end game when Thor briefly
regained mjolnir after swiping it from
the 2013 era in the time ice we know he
remains was aware of the Avengers time I
stand aware of Thanos he remains in Miss
minutes use Thanos in a multiple choice
question as an example and Brent Slayer
made it clear that he remained scripted
The Avengers manipulating the timeline
what they did was supposed to happen you
escaping was not there are also hints
that he remains what's keeping his eye
on Thor's life events from the Loki
episode 6 opening Montage that includes
sound bites from the sacred timeline
that were quotes from he remains
transcript that he later showed eloki
and Sylvie if you listen closely you can
hear Thor from the grand Masters Arena
and Thor Ragnarok
dance off bro it's a friend from work
he's a friend from work and also Thor
from when he faces that big boy in that
Shield site in the 2011 Thor film
fought bigger this means it's some King
variant out there in the dynasty had his
eyes on Thor both before and after
mjolnir was destroyed he probably wanted
Target Thor before mjolnir was destroyed
because even though Thor seemed at his
most vulnerable during the events of
Ragnarok he was teamed up with Valkyrie
and Hulk and Loki for a lot of that and
Lucy millionaire is what helped Thor
discover the inner God of thunderpowers
and then after that in Infinity War Thor
acquired a god-killing weapon that he
used to get Thanos and Kang Not only
would not have wanted to get in front of
Thor not going for the head I think he
wanted that Stormbreaker battle ax to
later lava thanos's head so again it
just makes way more sense for Kang to
Target Thor when he was still to use
Odin's rhetorical words the god of
hammers now of course we are talking
about the Multiverse here so really
we're talking about Kang killing Thor
it's an alternate universe version of
history and we actually saw one where
that could have happened the 838
Universe for Multiverse Madness that
Illuminati definitely did not have a
Thor now yes just because he was
exploded doesn't mean he's dead and
normally the Illuminati is not known for
having Thor or any other Asgardian on it
the roster consists of terrans and Taryn
and Jason's like Black Bolt but it has
now been more or less confirmed that the
Multiverse of Menace producers very
nearly included Daniel Craig as balder
the Brave on that 838 Illuminati lineup
Alder being Thor's Asgardian half
brother so clearly they didn't have
issues with n as guardian being on the
lineup and would have needed some reason
why it couldn't be Thor in that reality
in other words it's theoretically
conceivable that they intended Thor to
be dead in the 838 universe and by they
in the universe we should start assuming
the antecedent of that to be the Kang
Dynasty as a collective now there's some
precedence of Kang vs Thor conflicts in
the comics like there's the early 1967
Thor 140 in which Kang fought Thor by
unleashing the growing man on him to
test synthetic life forms on 20th
century Earth so that he can use them to
take over worlds in the future but to
identify Thor's Nexus moment in the MCU
we have to look closely at his Infinity
Saga history for most of that history
the Kang Dynasty theoretically would
have wanted to keep Thor alive because
Thor was instrumental in helping the
Avengers 50 Thanos in the time ice in
the Battle of Earth again according to
the TBA and he remains what the Avengers
did was supposed to happen but there is
one particular possible Nexus moment in
the infinity Saga that exposes Kang's
biggest blind spot that he would have
traced his vulnerabilities back to hey
we've got a new place to buy the coolest
stuff nerd riot.shop we took our merch
shop gave it a glow up and added a bunch
of cool new clothing and gear
hand-picked by the team at new rockstars
so if you've been obsessing over the
last of us as artists we have make sure
to toss a lost in the darkness tee into
your go bag before the next
post-apocalyptic cross-country road trip
and we have a very stylish line of
quantum media teas hoodies and beanies
featuring cool designs inspired by the
upcoming Marvel film Mt even came up
with one himself Based On Da Vinci's
Vitruvian man but with Kang in there
instead of a naked Italian dude we are
really excited that they are available
ahead of the release of the film so you
can order now and wear them to the
theater on opening night you can
exchange high fives with other members
of the Kang gang and the concession line
to get your hands on those and some very
stylish new rockstars logo designs head
to nerd riot.shop today and keep an eye
out for our upcoming me Mandalorian
season 3 designs join the riot over at
nerd riot.shop and it is lasted with
Thor than it does with vision Vision
represents a major vulnerability to Kang
because Multiverse event is established
Mission as one of the earliest thinkers
on the Multiverse what do you know about
the Multiverse the Multiverse this head
is theories he believed it was real and
dangerous well he was right about both
aha also in the Young Avengers Comics
it's Visions OS that Ken's young
kind-hearted variant Nate Richards uses
with to become the iron lad all in all
Kang hates Vision he's like 2019 Eric
Boss before one division hated his guts
thought there was no soul in there now I
love the guy who completely come around
on him not Kang though Kang hates a
stupid vibranium guts and if I am right
and Marvel Studios is looking closely at
Mark Wade's 2017 Avengers Unleashed Kang
War comic storyline to adapt the Kang
components of the Multiverse Saga Vision
was really the front man of that
Adventures conflict with Kang at that
time vision is the one who deduces that
in order to defeat Kang they must locate
Nathaniel Richards as a baby and then
we'll show us Rudy
as Kang Prime in that comic storyline
goes back to erase all the adventures
from their origin points left behind to
fight are figures like Hercules figures
from myth with less clear Origins and so
that gives us two possible reasons Kang
would Target the MCU Thor as an
Asgardian a demigod who would later
respawn in Valhalla upon dying in battle
and can later reincarnate in a new form
that would make Thor particularly
difficult to Snuff out but more
importantly in the MCU Thor and
specifically mjolnir were these specific
factors that spawned Vision Vision in
Avengers Age of Ultron acquired its name
directly from Thor's Mystic vision of
the Infinity Stones and a mind Stone he
got escaped by looking over at Thor and
mirroring him and as a synthazoid
composed of ultron's vibranium infused
tissue and a mind a mix of Jarvis's OS
and a mind Stone it was truly the final
garnish of Thor's blast of lightning
from mjolnir that truly Frankenstein's
Vision to life without this moment
vision would not exist this was vision's
birth and therefore to erase Vision in
the MCU to stop the mcu's most advanced
mind from out thinking the Kang Dynasty
Kang would need to physically remove
Thor from that equation in Age of Ultron
the one with the hammer it's not just
Thor a Norse god that Kang quantumania
remembers it's the Avenger that used a
hammer to breathe life into the Avenger
that represents Kang's biggest
vulnerability that I think is the
likeliest option the exact moment Kang
would have killed Thor in another
timeline you may have noticed I am
wearing our Quantum minions fired Kang
rain Eternal shirts you can get this
over at nerd riot.shop a reminder to
subscribe please please please do the
Deep dive you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at EA boss follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign